are we ready okay good there we are
hello can you hear me okay excellent
hi everyone my workshop Norwegians did a
much better job of greeting me hi okay
excellent you're here then you're awake
good thanks for coming everyone
my name is Brock Allen I'm a consultant
I call myself an identity architect
these days kind of a nifty nifty unique
title I basically help companies with
their identity architecture and their
application security and I focus on
things like you know Identity Management
storing passwords you know doing MFA
getting users logged into systems very
often doing things like single sign-on
with open ID Connect having apps invoke
api's you know securely with oauth2 and
a lot of that also then revolves around
right once we know who the user is what
can they do in the apps so when I'm not
doing work for customers in those topics
I spend a lot of my time doing some
open-source work on a couple projects
called identity server and identity
model identity server is a framework for
helping you build open ID connect and
ooofff to servers to help achieve those
identity architectures of single sign-on
and identity model is like a little
helper library that you can use from an
app to connect to those servers I also
do some commercial product work for
authorization in something called policy
server so this session is about how from
JavaScript applications running in the
browser we can authenticate calls
securely back to our web api's I'm
mainly talking you know about
client-side browser-based applications
I'm not talking about when I'm saying
JavaScript not talking about server-side
node.js type of apps so these are purely
client-side browser based JavaScript
applications so what we're going to do
is look at a couple different approaches
for authenticating calls when you're
making these Ajax calls back to the
server and then we'll talk about couple
of threats you need to be aware of when
you're building your JavaScript spa
applications the majority of the session
is about mitigating against one of those
threats which is a cross-site request
forgery attack and
we're gonna see a couple different or a
few different styles for protecting
those api's depending on your apt
requirements and and you know what what
what architecture you kind of need based
on your your you know your identity
architecture for your your applications
so when we have JavaScript running and
browsers we have a couple different
styles for how we make calls back to the
server and authenticate those calls
so one kind of half of those apps that I
think of I think of the more traditional
or the older applications that you might
be building where you have some
server-side code running that maybes
rendering HTML and that server-side code
needs to know who the user is so chances
are because you have a server-side
application you're using a cookie of
some sort to do authentication right
very very traditional type of thing and
then you know one day you discovered
something like jQuery and you're like oh
wow I can actually put code in the
browser right and do something more
dynamic and I can make Ajax calls back
to my server and it just sort of worked
an authentication just worked in those
Ajax calls basically because you were
sending a cookie along okay and that's
kind of what we like about cookies for
authentication is because the browser is
automatically or implicitly sending them
to the server so totally works for Ajax
calls and you know that's why we like it
it's nice and easy okay so that's one
style the other style is more the the
the newer style of JavaScript or spa
applications that we're developing these
are more like pure angular or react
where you're building the application so
that the entire UI is executing and
rendering in the browser and you really
have nothing on the server other than an
API somewhere and that might not even be
running with your app that may be on a
totally different domain somewhere and
so that's almost a style or maybe you
could even deploy it from a CDN okay you
have nothing really executing on the
server so how you authenticate that
style of app well you actually have a
couple more choices there you could
still try to do cookies if you had
something server-side but another
architectures use token-based
authentication and we're going to talk
about sort of the pros and cons of those
so the couple main threats that you need
to be aware of when you're building
JavaScript applications running in the
browser right the first and foremost is
cross-site scripting attacks okay so
that's you know one of the still most
many types of attacks on the web where
an attacker can somehow pass parameters
into your application your application
interprets them as you know some sort of
input but you're interpreting it in
executing it accidentally in your
application right string concatenation
and it's the same idea with server-side
things like sequel injection so a couple
of the mitigations that you probably are
already using but if you're not you need
to be aware of them is obviously HTTP
only cookies is one thing to use there
right the idea there is that when you
issue your cookie from your server-side
application you don't want the
cross-site scripting attack in your page
or in your users app to somehow
exfiltrate the cookie because then the
attacker could just send the cookie out
to their you know to their server and
then replay the cookie into your app and
of course they're in that's a really
easy mitigation because you can just
mark it in the cookie and it just
happens automatically because the
browser is enforcing it so that's a nice
mitigation it's not really necessarily
the best mitigation because of course if
the attacker is running JavaScript in
the page well they can just submit Ajax
calls back to the server as if it's the
user so you know protecting its
exfiltration of the cookie is only one
sort of a defense so yeah we still need
to protect against that code running in
the page because then it could do
whatever the user is doing so content
security policy right is a very
important feature for doing that how
many of you use this today actually
that's pretty decent it's a quarter of
you
that's better than you know maybe a year
ago so if you're building a spa
JavaScript application just hands-down
you should absolutely using content
security policy and the talk is not
about content security policy but I will
briefly show you or mention what it's
about so the idea is I'm just using a
github as an example here when your HTML
page renders from the server and renders
into the browser you can emit a HTTP
header from your server-side application
called content security policy and this
is basically a feature of browsers
modern browsers and you're basically
telling the browser that you don't want
any JavaScript to run on the page okay
and that's actually gonna solve our
cross-site scripting problem right
absolutely
no JavaScript no attack okay ah right
you
building a spy I forgot okay so we
actually want to protect or enable other
parts of the application to run which is
your code the the legitimate code okay
so basically the way this works you
added in the page it disables pretty
much all JavaScript and then the idea is
you come down here and with some
additional directives you are telling
the browser which scripts you do trust
or you do want to allow to run and there
are a variety of ways of doing this one
way is you can indicate that the host
name or the domain name that your
scripts are coming from that you trust
if that's a CDN I don't know if that's
gonna really help you because a bad guy
can also put their script up on a CDN
but if it's your own domain you can do
that there's another technique where you
can even do the hash of the block of
JavaScript that you want to allow to run
okay that's actually really locking it
down okay
so again this talk is not really about
that but if you don't know about it you
really should be using it and use it and
introduce it as soon as possible into
your application architecture as
possible because the more you're you're
basically deliberately restricting
things that can run on the page and so
if you have a whole bunch of JavaScript
that you're building that goes off and
does inline scripting and things like
that you're really you know kind of
painting yourself into court you're
making it harder for you be able to use
this okay so again you should be using
this for any kind of JavaScript you're
running in the browser
alright this by the way has other
features as well it's not just what
JavaScript can run it's like what CSS
can run you know what domains can you
connect back to for Ajax calls and
WebSockets what web fonts will you allow
to run
what origins you know iframes are
allowed to be running which form which
origins you can post your forum post
from a form element all kinds of things
like that so you really should look into
this and you know be using it in your
apps it's gonna be your your best
defense against cross site scripting
because it's really the browser who is
sandboxing your app and helping you out
okay so the other main attack which is
really what the rest of this talk is
about it's something called cross-site
request forgery and we have a few
different mitigations against that like
I said depending on your application
architecture so real quick what is a
cross-site request forgery attack the
idea is that you have logged in to an
application and
again this is the scenario where we're
using cookies to authenticate our Ajax
calls so the server-side application
your users gonna go log into that
username password whatever you're gonna
get back a cookie into your browser
great your app can make requests that
cookie gets sent your app can make Ajax
calls the cookie is sent great now my
the end user is somehow fooled into
opening up another tab they to go to
some malicious website and that
malicious website also makes requests
over to your application okay something
like a get request maybe they put an
image tag over to your some endpoint in
your application or they have a form
element all right just some action in
your application and then they write a
line of JavaScript to auto submit it
okay
this is something you need to protect
against because when the attacker runs
that code in the user's browser the
cookie will be sent okay so even though
the page submitting to your application
is from an entirely different domain
because your app previously issued the
cookie the browser is gonna
automatically send it that's just how
cookies have worked forever
okay so again the attack here is the
attacker is taking advantage of the fact
that your browser implicitly sends the
cookie okay this by the way is also a
valid attack if you're using other types
of credentials that the bread that the
browser is implicitly sending if you're
doing integrated windows authentication
if you're doing HTTP basic
authentication where the browser prompts
right or if you're doing even like
client certificates like an x.509
certificate you know we're a smart card
and the browser prompts you for it and
you send it in all of those credentials
you've asked the browser to kind of
manage and therefore implicitly send on
every request okay so all those
scenarios you need to protect against so
how do we do that one approach is
something with an anti forgery token an
anti forgery token is basically think of
it as like a credential that proves that
your app is the one making request your
your HTML is making the request back to
your server-side application and so the
the trick about this is that your
application or your HTML has to
explicitly send the value okay that's
kind of the difference right instead of
an imp
it's an explicit credential and so this
is pretty easy to do if you're doing
like asp.net or even MVC because what
happens is when your code is rendered
into the page right I'm sure you've all
seen this if you've done any kind of
Razer programming we're in the form tag
you put HTML dot anti forgery token okay
and what that does is it creates a
random value that's the anti forgery
token it issues it in a cookie and it
renders the value that random value into
this form element as a hidden field so
then whenever your page is posted back
with a normal button click like abnormal
submit right because that's just a
hidden input that's in your form it's
automatically sent along and on the
server you have that validate anti
forgery token attribute and that code on
the server reads the cookie reads the
hidden form value and compares it to and
what that's doing is proving that the
form that submitted the page came from
your server it's your code okay an
attacker on their website they could
make the call the anti forgery cookie
would be sent but they have no way to
know the value in that cookie because
the cookie came from your domain so they
can't read it and it's such a high
entropy value that they would never
guess the right value to put in here so
then when they submit it just won't
match and your server can reject the
call okay this technique has been around
for a very very long time right
the trick is or at least when it comes
to JavaScript applications did you
remember to send it when you made your
Ajax calls right did you remember to
send along the ante forgery value that
was from the hidden field when you do
dollar sign dot you know Ajax right
using jQuery or something like that very
often people forget when they're just
adding a little bit JavaScript to the
page to make that call ooh they forget
to actually send along that ante forgery
value so for those particular endpoints
you might have the possibility of a
cross-site request forgery attack okay
so that's a concern so anyway that's one
too one way to sort it out so you could
use cookies and as long as every request
you're standing in anti forgery value
you've protected those calls okay that's
one style now turns out there's actually
a newer feature in the last
yeah six or nine months the browsers are
really starting to implement and it's
something called same site cookies okay
what a same site cookie is is basically
when you issue the authentication cookie
the cookie you're using to know who the
user is in your application you can add
this new attribute called same site and
that's a flag to the browser so again
we're gonna fall back and have the
browser help protect our application it
tells the browser that this cookie
should only ever be sent back to the
server if the page making the request is
from the same domain okay so that
totally solves the problem because now
when you go to the malicious domain the
other tab in the browser it's from a
different domain it makes the
cross-domain call and the browser
basically says oh the cookies not
supposed to go cross domain so therefore
the browser will prevent it okay I don't
know why they didn't do this ten years
ago honestly this really would have
helped us a long time ago in terms of
you know helping us with this cross-site
request forgery vulnerability and
basically this is a substitute for using
an T forgery okay the only gotcha about
this is that it is as I said sort of a
newer feature so depending on the the
browsers that you have to support you
may not have you know not have this
available to you
so if you have to support like an older
Android or iOS version running older
versions of those browsers or Safari it
looks like only the current version has
it or even the point release so you know
I don't know if you can quite totally
rely upon this feature but I think in
the next six to twelve months you'll be
able to okay alright so that is another
approach for addressing the cross-site
request forgery issue is to use same
side cookies and again you're letting
the browser do the protection for us
okay now there's got to be a down side
the same side cookies which is yeah
there's a some architectural constraints
there one is that your API has to have
something on the server side that issues
the cookie okay some api's aren't built
that way right they're built to just
sort of be standalone you call them and
they don't think about the fact that
there's a browser there I guess that
also means that you have to have a
browser being the client application so
if that API wanted to be in
by some server-to-server call or some
mobile app that you're building
yeah those don't do cookies so that's
also a problem what else oh of course it
has to be in the same domain right
that's what same site cookies mean right
if you're trying to if you have to call
these at cross domain you know that's
not gonna work either and what else well
I guess that the same side cookies are
still new so you know there might be
some architectural reasons why you can't
use same site cookies okay so what are
we gonna do instead well there's a
different architecture that uses
something called a token based
authentication design if you will a
token again is just another type of
credential the main difference is that
this is something that needs to be sent
explicitly so this token is usually a
JSON web token or a jot if you've ever
heard of those I'm sure you have this is
sent as the authorization header
explicitly every time you make a call
like an ajax call okay and so again this
basically gives us a level of
indirection from the browser right so
it's not a cookie that's a really a
browser feature it's just an independent
thing that can be sent on every call and
it can be validated these are
self-contained they have a digital
signature so they can't be tampered with
they can be obtained by any type of app
so it just doesn't have to be just a
browser-based application we can call
cross-domain there are lots of lots of
nice benefits for this architecture it
is more complex though okay so this is a
trade off for those benefits so how do
we get these tokens well guess what
there's some protocols for that okay so
there are a couple protocols open ID
connect and ooofff to open ID Connect is
built on top of OAuth 2 so you typically
you are using them at the same time and
basically the design of these protocols
is you actually get two tokens one token
is meant to be used to call to the API
and that's something called an access
token and then there's another token
called an identity token that is meant
to be consumed by the front end of the
application and that's for the
authentication piece of things so your
JavaScript app might like to say welcome
back Brock and then the JavaScript spa
wants to call an API okay so the ID
token is going to contain my name for
the front end and the access token will
be used to call to the backend ok so
these are the protocols that are the
the standards for building a spa to
obtain these type of tokens basically
the high-level architecture is you're in
your spa
you are gonna typically redirect the
user to someplace that issues these
tokens and so we call that thing the
token server that implements these
protocols the user will do their
authentication their username and
password login with Google whatever and
then it will issue tokens back to the
app and then the app will of course use
the tokens to call the backend API so
really that back-end call is just that
access token and that identity token is
meant to stay in the spa to let the the
front-end know who that user is okay so
the details of this sort of redirection
to the token server and the you know
receiving the results back into your
client app the OAuth in the open ID
Connect specification describes these as
flows or protocol flows and there are a
few different flows in the protocol for
different application scenarios there's
some flows for where you have a service
server call and there's no user and
there are other flows where you have a
front-end and users interacting with the
app and we need to do this redirect in
the browser so there is actually been
some some changes in the the spec
recommendations in the last six or nine
months a while ago or when the OAuth
specs originally came out the flow that
they recommended for spas was something
called implicit flow and it turns out
that the movement and the spec committee
is to deprecated the implicit flow
mainly because when the implicit flow
was first being developed it was way
back in 2012 and to use the the code
flow which is actually the primary
recommended one to use the code flow
there are certain API calls that do have
to happen cross domain and so at the
time to do cross domain calls for that
to work the browser had to support
course okay well at that time cores
really wasn't widely deployed so they
couldn't take a dependency on it so
that's why they had to come up with this
implicit flow which was like a shortcut
version an optimized version of these
protocol flows to accommodate the fact
that these you know browser-based apps
were we're a little bit hobbled because
of the nature of
you know cross-domain calls since then
though of course more and more browsers
are implementing course and so now the
spec committee said hey yeah we've
always wanted to do something better
more modern or more you know and also a
consistent flow so they have now moved
back to using the authorization code
flow as the primary recommended approach
for these spas because again now we can
do cores and do these cross-domain calls
when you need to invoke back to the
token server okay now it turns out their
authorization code flow itself has some
problems there's a substitution attack
called the the code substitution attack
and so since then the working groups
have also added another RFC to kind of
fix the hole or patch it if you will so
what they've introduced is another
specification called pixie the pke is
the acronym there stands for proof key
for code exchange so the idea is that
you need to be using code flow with this
pixie spec to have a nice secure
approach for your browser-based
application so I'm going to talk through
the details of that and hopefully it'll
make more sense so what this means is
that your spa needs to go and talk to
this token server through these
protocols for the token server for your
app to talk to the token server the
token server has to have certain
endpoints these endpoints are defined by
the specification so one of these
endpoints is called the discovery
document it has metadata about your
token server there's an endpoint called
the authorization endpoint this is the
interactive endpoint that you redirect
the user to and then there's a
programmatic endpoint called the token
endpoint and that's the one that we will
now be invoking to get our tokens so
here's what the discovery document might
look like it's basically a URL under the
base address of your token server I
don't know if you guys can see here if
this is the base address of your token
server then the discovery document is
always under this well-known path it
serves up Jason so that your client
application can then know the other
metadata it needs about the token server
namely what are the two URLs for the
other endpoints that I need to interact
with just makes easier for your app to
configure against the token server so
the protocol works like this their users
in the spa
basically the the spouse's a I need you
to go login okay so it ends up
redirecting the user to the authorized
endpoint okay again to know the
authorized endpoint it probably first
made an AJAX call that loads the
discovery document then we know the URL
we redirect the user to that authorized
endpoint
there are several parameters that are
passed to the authorized endpoint to let
the token server know what app is making
the request that's the client ID and
where to send the results which is the
redirect URI and the one thing about
which protocol flow here this parameter
called response type that is actually
what is controlling the fact that we are
now using code flow instead of the prior
implicit flow if you are familiar with
that so there's some other parameters
here the other main one here is the fact
that I want some access to some identity
information so this open ID in profile
these are called scopes which allow the
app to get user information this is what
is going to affect the claims that come
back in this identity token so the front
end can say welcome back brach you know
your first name last name whatever other
information and then of course Oh
actually emails on there as well
I missed that one and then the other
thing that you want access to are a
certain api's so there are other scopes
here that represent the api's that the
spa wants to invoke and so api one and
api to those are going to affect the
access token and allow you to call those
two different api's okay so what happens
then is the request goes to the token
server the user then will log into the
token server with whatever you know type
of account the user will have there so
it could be password could be you know
social logins could be a business login
Federation with Azure Active Directory
whatever and then the token service is
great you're now logged in we know who
you are and you will get a cookie at the
token server that represents your single
sign-on session and then the token
server redirects back to the application
with a parameter called a code this is
what's called the authorization code
this is not the access token this is not
the identity token but it is the thing
that will get you to the tokens okay now
in the implicit flow the prior flow that
was dead
brocaded what would happen is the tokens
would be sent directly in this in this
URL okay right there in the URL back to
the spa the spa could then just read
them and start using them okay that was
the main complaint about the prior flow
is the fact that it's in the URL and
it's in your history right of your
browser and maybe your browser is
pulling in you know images from
someplace and those may leak out as
refer headers okay now there were things
to do to mitigate against this like the
parameters were actually passed in the
hash fragment that was supposed to
protect against that the history was
still a problem but you could write
JavaScript to clear the history so the
older-style was sort of the best that we
had and there were mitigating could do
to clean it up and make it a little
tighter but anyway the spec committee
said no we really want the spec to just
have built in a nice clean approach to
making sure that you don't have to know
to do all these extra things so that's
why we now get this code okay now the
code is received back in your spa and
the spa will now make programmatic calls
to the token server to that token
endpoint that I mentioned and this is
where we exchanged the code for the
tokens okay which is the access token is
what we're gonna use to call our API so
you might look at this and say hmmm well
if we change the protocol flow to use
code flow because we didn't like the
stuff in the URL was maybe you know you
could somehow capture that
well what would prevent us from
capturing the code as well and just
making the same call to this token
endpoint to get the tokens okay now if
you've ever done o author open ID
Connect in the past you've probably seen
sometimes if you're building a
server-side app you'll get a client ID
and a client secret and it's that
server-side secret that is protecting
the code so that nobody can steal it and
use it as an attack vector well in a spa
can we embed a secret somewhere in your
JavaScript yeah not really okay so this
is where the other spec that I mentioned
proof key for code exchange or pixie
comes in what it does is it allows us to
protect the code here with sort of a
dynamic or a temporary secret and so the
way that works is I'm going to go
a couple slides notice them when we made
a request of the authorized endpoint
this is basically using code flow with
pixie by that extra parameter called
code challenge what the spa is going to
do before it makes the request out to
the to the authorized endpoint is it
dynamically creates a secret and we're
only ever going to use the secret for
this one exchange with the token server
so we don't try to store it anywhere we
just create it and hold it in memory so
you have a secret the protocol then has
you hash that secret and that's this
code challenge parameter so what we're
doing is we're sending a hash of a
dynamically generated secret okay then
once we get back to the code the token
server when it generates the code it's
also storing the hashed version of the
secret okay
right so now your JavaScript gets back
this code it makes an ajax call back to
the token server back to the token
endpoint it passes its client ID the
code and then the original dynamically
generated secret okay that's by the way
called the code verifier so on the token
server we had the hashed version so what
it says is hey I see your code great I
can look up my data in the database I
have your hash secret oh but you're
passing to the plaintext as the code
verifier so the token server will hash
the incoming code verifier compare the
hashes and now know that the app making
the back-channel call or to the token
endpoint call with this code is the same
app that made the front channel call
so it's guaranteeing or ensuring that if
somebody has intercepted this code in
transit that you know they're running on
some other server they won't be able to
actually exchange the code for the
tokens okay that's what pixie is all
about and it turns out that in the spec
committee all of the flows that we've
ever used in the past this is now v
recommended flow really for all of them
so if you have a server-side web
application switch over and you can use
code flow with pixie instead of like
hybrid flow if you're running a mobile
app right you can run a mobile app do
the same protocol flow code flow with
pixie okay so really the nice thing
about this is that
you know if you've ever learned about
the stuff in the last two to three years
you have all these flows you have to
remember and hybrid flow in this flow
and that flow it's really simple now for
an interactive app with a human in front
of it code flow with pixie right that's
it just one to learn okay oh and by the
way the asp.net core team in 3.0 is
adding code flow with pixie to their
Open ID Connect middleware for your MVC
style apps okay good so the results from
that token endpoint are the identity
token and the access token I mentioned
that these tokens are the identity token
is something called a jot this is
basically a JSON data structure that is
encoded has a digital signature on it
contains some protocol claims but the
other main thing it contains are the
claims the information about your user
that you had asked for with those scopes
so we asked for the scope open ID that
means I want the subject claim which is
the users unique ID I also asked for the
email scope which means I want some
email claims I also asked I think for
profile that which is like your name
your first name your last name things
like that maybe we didn't get those back
you know but the idea is those are the
claims you're getting back and these are
meant this ID token and the claims
inside are meant for the front end
portion of the app the ID token is only
used by the but the spot itself okay
then we have this access token and
that's what's used to actually make our
Ajax call back to the server and of
course on the server side you have to
you know validate that so here's some
JavaScript that shows you how old I am
right basically doing some old-school
xml httprequest I'm gonna set the
request header which is the
authorization header and you use the
bearer scheme and that's where you pass
along the access token and this is how
the token gets sent on every call to the
token server and then you process the
results you know normally okay and then
on the server the web API that you're
actually invoking needs to author you
know validate that incoming access token
and if you're using asp.net core or oh
and katana
there's
helpers in those frameworks for that so
I understand people use other tech
stacks as well but whatever tech stack
you're using there's gonna be some
equivalent piece of middleware or
infrastructure server side that will
validate these tokens okay okay so I do
have some sample code so let's switch
over and do that I just wanted to kind
of get everybody on the same page in
terms of the protocol flows what I have
here is now a very very simple spa
application okay and again you can
obviously tell my design skills are on
par with my security skills here so here
I have a very simple spa or JavaScript
application
I'm gonna go log the user in I'm gonna
then you know get some tokens back I'm
gonna say oh you're Brock welcome back
have my API access token to call my API
and then we'll talk a couple other
application things like renewing tokens
there's a concern there and of course
logging the user out okay so the way
this works is that I'm actually using a
helper library called OAD C client this
is a JavaScript library that I actually
built and had certified by the Open ID
foundation to be spec compliant at the
time I was building this stuff there
were no JavaScript libraries out there
to do these protocols so I had to build
one okay and so the idea is I'm pulling
this in here right this library
I have my you know event handlers for my
buttons and then what I'm gonna do is
set up some configuration and this is
configuring a building the configuration
for my JavaScript client application so
there are some settings here like what's
the token server that I'm trusting so I
just have a test token server up up in
the cloud
this is actually a copy an instance of
identity server we have to configure
things like the client ID the response
type in the scope those should look
familiar from the prior slide because
these are the parameters that we send on
the protocol this library does in fact
support code flow with pixee ok so
there's actually a customer here in
europe that sponsored that feature at
the end of last year so thanks for that
and so here we are now with support for
your spa for the the proper you know the
recommended protocol this only supports
code flow with pixie right so you can
pop that in here and it's going to
automatically do the pics
peace right so you configure this stuff
we come down here and then we create an
instance of this user manager class the
user manager is going to do two major
things for us one is all the protocol
work so it knows how to build the URL to
the authorized endpoint and make calls
back to the token endpoint as I
described earlier
it also does your session management
within the spa which means when we get
the results back we have to kind of keep
track that there is a user sitting here
and so really what that means is that
there's some storage in the browser that
the these results are kept in and that's
where your tokens reside okay so when we
load up the application here what we're
gonna do is invoke this first helper
here called get user this will let you
know well this will attempt to read the
storage and see if there is in fact
already a session so if there is a
session you'll get back a user object
which is really just a deserialized
object from the storage the JSON that's
in storage great so we'll have a user
and this user object has your tokens
your ID token your access token the
access token being the thing that you
care about to call your API and it will
also have any of the claims that came
back in the ID token so this library
deals with parsing the ID token and
doing all of the the work necessary to
get the the users information for you so
there's a profile property where all
those things hang off of okay so if you
have a session you're good to go if not
well then I just print out the fact that
I don't have a user right now and which
is exactly why that's being printed okay
all right so of course when I click my
login button I'm gonna go trigger the
redirect to go login right this is like
sending your user to your login page
except it just happens to be in a
different domain it's the token server
that you've established trust with so
we're gonna send the user away and when
they come back as you notice my redirect
URI I'm sending them back to my callback
to HTML page so in here I'm basically
reinstating the user manager and calling
the corresponding paired method if you
will so I do sign-in redirect to get the
user out and then I'm using sign and
redirect callback to process the results
when they come back in okay inside of
this call it does
it grabs the code from the URL it makes
the call back to the token server
exchanging it for the tokens and doing
the rest of the protocol work necessary
to know that that's all valid ok it then
takes the results stores it in storage
right which is your tokens and the
information about your user and then
we'll raise the success event here and
you'll be able to then do whatever you
need to do next which in this case I'm
just gonna take the user back to the my
little home page okay so then back on my
home page when I reload right because
that storage will have survived the page
redirect yeah I'll just load up and now
I should see that we have a user session
ok so let's give that a try I will call
login and actually not only do that one
more time in the debugger here or not
the debugger per se but the network
trace right so what I'll do here call
login ok so a couple things that happen
first is for my JavaScript app to first
know what the URL is for the
authorization endpoint it first
actually queries that discovery endpoint
that I mentioned and it's getting back
all that JSON and with the JSON now it
knows the actual URL for the authorized
endpoint and as you can tell it has
built up the parameters for that request
including our client ID our redirect URI
here is the fact we're easing code flow
here the Scopes I configured and if you
look here aha here's the code challenge
that I talked about so that's that pic
see that dynamic secret that's being
generated hashed and sent along great so
now let's come in here and actually log
in Alice and Alice of course ok we come
back to my application and where did we
pick up here so we came back to my
application we ended up going back to my
call back page from the token server the
token server had sent back the code all
right a few other parameters coming back
my call back page loads up my library re
queries the discovery document so it now
knows the token endpoint and if you see
the call as being made to the token
endpoint and if we scroll down far
enough you'll see that the authorization
code is being passed along with the code
verifier which is the plain text version
of that dynamic secret okay and what
came back from that was a few other
things like our tokens and after all of
that then the session was established by
putting a record in session storage so
the library chooses session storage by
default because that's just per window
so if you close the browser or close the
window that data is gone you can swap
this out and use something else like
local storage or even indexdb but I
think I actually prefer the the session
storage approach and so what's in here
is you can tell is just a JSON object
that's been serialized and it has the
access token and the ID token and this
profile then is where all the claims
came back that I had mentioned that are
from the ID token okay so now this
access token if I look at the sky and
we're on a website called JMS pop the
access token in here you can see that
now this access token is intended to be
used at my API okay and this has things
like hey here's your users unique ID
subject ID one that's Alice's one okay
so anyway that's the access token that I
would then send to my API so this
storage here for my user right has all
these things in it and when I call my
get user well as you can tell that user
object I got back is just the
deserialized object and then I'm just
rerender it on the page so we can see
what's inside so yeah when you make that
call back to get the user you have the
dot access token and you have dot
profile dot name dot email dot whatever
you whatever you need okay all right so
how do we then invoke the API well of
course I met a little call API method
here I'm gonna reload my user I'm doing
my old-school Ajax call I'm sending my
request my authorization header based on
the access token and if that all works I
should be able to see that yeah I was
able to pass that access token and just
to show you on the network here right I
was able to pass that bearer token along
and here it is in the outgoing header
okay the API then was a
to validate it and all the API is doing
is then just echoing back the contents
of the access token just so we can see
that it worked okay great
cool any questions about that yeah talk
loud so why is the secret passes plain
text on the token request because you
have to prove that you have the secret
yeah then then what was the point of
hashing it in the first place the hash
becomes the secret itself so yeah I see
what you're saying they actually have a
provision in the SPAC if if your client
side app can't do hashing you can just
do plain text but yeah I mean that's how
the spec was written so oh so the
question is just related probably to my
comment about all the other protocol
flows are now using code flow with pixie
or that's an encouraged flow yeah I mean
in a sense in theory the client I do
could go away I'm sorry the client
secret could go away which is what you
asked for
there might be other interactions though
and that your app does need to make to
the token server for other things or
that client secret still is needed okay
so refresh tokens would be one of the
prime examples of that okay now one
thing I actually want to show you here
is that notice I did not obtain a
refresh token in this workflow so for
those of you who know about refresh
tokens it's a way to renew access and
get new token so that's actually the
next thing I'm going to talk about which
is this renew token so for server side
apps sure you can still use refresh
tokens the way we've been using them for
a long time but in that guidance that
was put out by the IETF to now ease that
you can move to code flow with with
pixie they actually have deliberate a
section here that explicitly indicates
reefer
tokens in the spa since you don't have a
secret are very powerful things and if
that Refresh token is ever exfiltrated
from your app now an attacker can just
keep getting new access tokens without
you know on behalf of the user
without anybody you know necessarily
knowing now there are other mitigations
you can take other hardening you can do
in your token server you can do one-time
Refresh tokens you can invalidate the
entire session if that fails but I've
not seen any token server even identity
server itself doesn't have all the the
protection measures specifically for
refresh tokens without secrets for spas
so there are things that that spec
suggests but they're still working on it
and they really need to flesh out the
guidance there so at this point in time
it's not really recommended to use
refresh tokens from these spas okay now
the thing that we kind of want in the
future is something called a a sender
constrained token and a sender
constrained token is a token that
basically is tied to the caller so there
was a feature a while ago that the that
the HTML or HTTP spec group was working
on called HTTP token binding and it was
basically a specification that allowed
you to issue a token and they I think
intended it for cookies but we could
also do it for these type of tokens
where the cookie when the website issued
it the cookie would actually be
cryptographically bound to the TLS
session so if somebody ever stole the
cookie and tried to submit it from
another TLS connection it would be would
detect this and reject it so that same
technique could be added to these tokens
okay that's the concept of a sender
constrained token somebody else can't
still send that token unfortunately so
the OAuth working group went and tried
to you know start lever building new
specs for tokens on top of this HTTP
token binding and then Google one day
said Oh where's she gonna remove that
feature from our browser we don't think
it's terribly useful okay and because
Google has you know such dominance with
their their you know users using browser
browser it kind of killed the whole
possible
of us relying upon that as a technique
so there has now been work in the OAuth
working group on a new way to do sender
constrain tokens for JavaScript apps
something called deep hop it's
demonstration of a proof of possession
token and it's basically relying upon
the same concept web crypto and
basically trying to have some sort of
private you know public private key pair
in that instance of the browser and you
when you're doing your connection to the
token server the tokens you get back are
now tied to that so if the token is ever
exfiltrated it'll be detected and
prevented so until we have that sort of
sorted out okay
you know the recommendation is stay away
from refresh tokens in the spa ok
that was like the longest answer for a
question I think so anyway ok so I have
a few other few minutes more I can talk
about a couple more topics here so the
next one is obviously access token that
you got back is usually only good for
about one hour and so the app can use
the access token over and over and over
at that API or however many API is it's
good for for that hour but at some point
it's going to expire and you know like a
cookie and a normal web app you can
issue your own new cookie you can slide
your own cookie because your app is the
one consuming it and your the app will
app is the one creating it we can't do
that here because our app didn't create
the token and the access token it was
the token server so what we need to do
is kind of like go back to the token
server right see look at the bottom I
have my expiration here I'm going back
to the token server and I'm going back
to the authorized endpoint the same one
I used at the very beginning to login
it's immediately coming back because I
have a single sign-on session right I
have a cookie at the token server that
represents my session over there so this
is actually working just fine
or you could probably tell I'm getting
new tokens as well if you can see that
yeah I'm still getting new tokens not a
problem the only problem is the
usability is pretty bad ok so it turns
out what the spec has you do is that
same login request right that you're
happening in the main window you can use
that sort of time-honored like
rock-solid HTML technology that we've
been using for years and years and years
to make requests to other websites
so the user can't see it and that is
iframes exactly okay so basically we can
use an iframe or make the same request
in an iframe to obtain new tokens and
that's exactly what my little renew
method here is going to do is if I
scroll down I've wired it up to my
method called silent of course because
it's a silent renew and the user manager
in the library that I'm showing you has
a sign in silence method so what this
does is it creates the exact same
authorized request it actually has one
more additional parameter called prompt
equals none and it's letting the token
server know that this is really in an
invisible request you know it's in a
hidden iframe so if it needs to show an
error page don't and just immediately
return back to the app so then this will
make the request of the token server in
the iframe I don't know if you noticed
up here at the top but we had a silent
redirect URI which was where the silent
response will be processed and the
remain difference between this one is
the response comes into the iframe and
the iframe isn't the one that wants to
deal with the tokens it wants to send
that up to the parent window so the
parent window will then actually
complete the processing and now have
updated tokens okay this is another
reason why by the way I am every time by
calling my API
I am reloading my user from storage
because the silent renew is just
updating storage right and you don't
want a cached version of the old access
token you want to every time you're
gonna call the API load the latest
version okay so that's the that's why
the call API is doing this okay so if I
hit f12 here go to my elements window
and doober a new token I don't know if
you guys can see at the bottom there's
an iframe being created every time I
click the button here and it's being
successful obviously it says here silent
render success so if I keep hitting this
you should see the expiration at the
bottom is getting updated and the values
and that token are being updated and
then that can be used to call the API
and that's the approach in your
JavaScript app where
you keep getting new tokens okay all
right a couple other things I have Oh
actually have a few minutes left here so
you might ask okay well when do I renew
this token well there are two approaches
one is you could keep using the access
token at the API and you'll get a 200
okay 200 okay 200 okay and then all of a
sudden you'll get a 401 ok 401 when
you're invoking an API means go get a
new token so that's pretty easy you
could just hook every where you get you
know response back from your API check
for 401 do the silent write get the
result and then reissue your API call
based on the new token okay the other
thing you could do though is if you
notice at the bottom so if I hit refresh
here yeah there we actually keep track
of when the token will be expiring
that's just the unix time of when it's
going to expire so you could imagine
another approach to renew tokens which
is you set up a timer right and you set
up a timer to proactively renew prior to
the expiration okay so the idea here is
that you can do this now I wouldn't
expect you guys to write that code it
turns out the library implements that
for you which is nice and nice and easy
and there is an add access token
expiring event that you can wire up to
so basically this guy internally is
already doing all of the calculations to
keep track of that so all you would need
to do is handle this event and then you
could actually do the silent call you
know inside of here yourself okay
there is even a flag on the settings
that will do all of that automatically
for you but when I first added that
setting originally I thought that was a
great idea but the only problem is if
you have the library keep automatically
renewing tokens when the user walks away
from the computer for 2 or 3 hours it's
gonna still keep getting tokens and
tokens and tokens so in retrospect I
kind of wish I had never added that
feature so that's why my recommendation
is now do it yourself right take the
silent call put it in here yourself but
put your own type of user activity
monitoring on top of that so if you
detect that the user is no longer active
you know you you want
automatically get tokens okay but you
figure out the right balance for that
for your app okay so the last thing we
have here is then the ability to sign
out and that's a pretty standard
protocol feature so we have a helper in
here or wherever it went to sign the
user out and when we sign them out we
have the ability to you know go send
them to log out of the tokens server and
then we can come back and you know go
back to the app and start over again
okay now actually check this out if I
try to renew my token right remember
that makes the same login request if I
did it in the main window would be
prompted with the login screen but if
you try to do the renewal in the iframe
because the prompt equals none parameter
is passed notice it immediately comes
back with an error and that's because
when we made the request
we sent prompt equals none and then
immediately came back with an error back
to that page because the token server
respects the fact oh you're in an iframe
there's nothing to show I just send back
an error okay cool I have a little bit
more time so I'll show you one last
little feature which is I'm gonna go
login and this last little feature is
great you're now logged in right as I
mentioned before we have a single
sign-on session at the token server so
you could go and launch two and three or
four more apps if they're all trusting
the same token server all of them will
just get you know signed in
automatically there's no more prompt for
a password great so let's say you have
your spa up in one tab and you have
another app up in the other tab and
another app in another tab and one of
them you click logout so now you're
gonna log out of that app you're gonna
go to the token server in that tab and
log out but what about those other two
or three apps that are in the other tabs
sitting around wouldn't it be nice if
they got notified that the user has
signed out in some sort of you know
other tab other window so it turns out
that the protocol supports that as well
so I'm actually gonna open up another
window to demo that so here I am if we
can see this I'm logged in and the other
tab okay and here over in the spa and
I'll show you the demo first then I'll
talk about how its implemented so the
idea is that now over on the right I'm
in the other tab I'm gonna go log out on
the token server okay oh I need to do my
demo better sorry I have an event in the
library which is called add user signed
out okay which is basically an event
that gets raised when this happens
okay so sorry let me run that one more
time okay log in Alice and Alice here so
back over here I'm now logged in I'll go
logout okay and again I don't trust my
cache so I'm gonna hit ctrl f5 one more
time okay good okay so now over here on
the right I will log out and here we go
okay took a little bit a while but not
so bad but the other tab said oh yeah
you're signed out and then your
JavaScript can you know say to the user
they I've noticed you signed out you
know you're done click here to start
over cool so that's kind of a nifty
thing this library supports that which
is basically a real simple event and
it's paying attention to what's
happening at the token server okay now
this is the interesting question is how
is my spa paying attention to what's
happening in at the token server okay so
the thing that we care about at the
token server is when the cookie is gone
if the cookies disappeared that means
you've signed out okay so can the
application running on localhost 5000
read the cookie from demo dot identity
server died oh yeah absolutely not right
cookies can't be Red Cross domain so how
does this work well it turns out that
the piece of code that can read the
cookie from the token server is a page
from the token server itself so one of
the features of the token server is this
something called the check session yes
iframe right yet another iframe and in
this page what's expected is your spa is
expected to open up an iframe to this
check session iframe endpoint and I
don't know if I just lost my internet
connection
come on is it February twenty-ninth it's
as you're restarting okay I think this
worked yeah okay good so what's
happening here is now the application is
opening up an iframe to this thing from
identity server itself so if you scroll
all the way down there's a bunch of
JavaScript in here but the thing that's
interesting is in the app on the right
or the the iframe it's listening for the
message event okay what's happening is
the spa has an identifier for the
current user session and it's every it's
setting up a timer and every two seconds
making a cross window call into this
okay and it's doing polling the thing is
that the polling is not Network polling
the polling is just crawling from one
window to the next okay once we're in
the iframe all of this has to do is take
the spa's session ID and see if it
matches the cookie that's in memory in
the browser that was issued from the
token server and if they're the same
then the page here responds back with a
message called unchanged so we send a
message back saying no nothing's changed
okay so every two seconds is it the same
session no nothing's changed is it the
same session nothing's changed then the
user logs out of the other tab the
session cookie is gone and now the next
time the the the JavaScript or the the
spa calls into the iframe the iframe
says oh your session ID doesn't match
anymore something in fact has changed
and then that's how the spa can detect
oh your session is no longer valid at
the token server okay sounds like quite
the hack doesn't it well that's exactly
what the spec told us to do so we did it
okay all right so now that's the last
kind of nifty little feature here with
this library is that you can track the
user session at the token server and be
notified for single sign out scenarios
okay okay so there's the library there's
the github repo with it if you're
interested in checking out the code we
already talked about the expiration the
that we're gonna do this silent renew
with an iframe and we're not going to be
using refresh tokens and we talked about
the couple of things related to signing
out and participating in the single sign
out notification okay so other that I am
done so again the summary here is if
you're building same site javascript spa
apps using an api totally use cookies
same site cookies are really going to be
the way to go but if you need a more
complex architecture then you're gonna
need me to move to tokens you can have
cross domain calls other apps using that
API you need a token server as well of
course and yes it is more complicated
but that's you know the price you need
to pay for that sort of flexibility in
that architecture okay so thank you so
much and enjoy the Booker's tonight
[Applause]